[Music]
developers looking for a way to store
secrets for their applications like
credentials often turn to the popular
secret management tool hasha core vault
in this video we'll cover how to
authenticate the [ __ ] core vault using
google cloud credentials i'm emily an
engineer working on Google cloud
platform and open source integrations
between cloud and house record fall and
I'm Andy a product manager at Hacha core
from the vault iam vault is a secrets
management tool that enables
organizations to centrally secure store
and access control secrets across
distributed infrastructure and
applications in the last video we
deployed our ATS video game application
hyperspace on Google cloud platform
using terraform today will be changing
gears a bit and talking about security
let's say we launch hyperspace a year
ago to great success and now we're
looking to monetize their game by
letting players buy extra life in order
to do that we need to accept payments
however the API key to our payment
gateways very sensitive if we were to
lose it someone malicious could possibly
steal our money this payments API key
what many developers referred to as a
secret weird the few escapes a lot from
the customers
how should I securely store secrets on
my applications need a build or runtime
developer working in public cloud or
multi cloud environments need a way to
store credentials configuration files
and many other secrets for both their
applications and themselves and he's
going to show us how to solve this on
gtp using vault I would open source tool
by hash Accord yes I am Hoshi core vault
manages storing encrypting and managing
access to secrets there's multiple
authentication backends which provide
different options for using your own
identities to identify users involved
vault also has many secret backends for
managing different kinds of Secrets like
the payments API key can you explain one
off indication back into Sandy great
question so vault behaves conceptually
similar to a website with multiple
authentication methods just like you can
log in with Google on a website
administrators can configure vault to
allow users or machines to log in and
access other secrets involved
vault is also pluggable so you can use a
built-in back-end or write your own
authentication method if you need to
that's right the LDAP or github awesome
Ekans are great options for developers
and say allow users to log in what's
LDAP or github API key in our case our
video game is running on TC instances so
the DCP off spec under the great choice
that doesn't pervert how does it work
well using this back-end developer their
applications cannot send
of all using two types of GCP
credentials the I am optional let's use
your I am servers account and the Google
compute engine or GCE metadata optional
of your GP instances to you find VM
metadata to install syndicate so the
video game GCE service can either use
their GCE metadata or their associated I
am service count to authenticate to
vault
yeah I think the GC method is especially
cool since the metadata token can be
obtained on startup without additional
authorization you won't need to hard
code any initial secrets into a startup
script or set super-secret environment
variables yeh no hard coding cherisa how
the authentication back-end works let's
do it alright so for this demo we've
already got a vault server up and
running on a separate GC instance and
someone has already stored our payments
API key as you can see in this terminal
we first sheldon's of instance that our
volt servers running on first an admin
for your vault server we'll need to
enable the authentication back-end next
the backend treats GCP as a trusted
third party so it needs credentials to
make calls to GCP api's to confirm
identity that admin can set these
credentials using the config endpoint
next admin needs to add roles vault has
the concept of policies which determine
what secrets are euler can access roles
bind these predefined policies to
generate a toss tokens to restrict what
secrets can be accessed by user on our
server we've already added the payments
policy that allows access to our API key
so let's add a GCE role we mentioned
that the back-end allows either GC
instances or I am service accounts to
authenticate is that what the GCE type
argument means that's correct
I mean so back-end will expect GC
metadata when authenticating under this
role we've also added a project ID and
bounds own to only authorized any GC
instances in this project and zone and
also use things like instance groups
labels or associated service accounts to
limit what instances can login under
this role so now the GCV back-end is set
up how do we actually authenticate to
vault that's which terminals we've
shelled into one of our games front-end
VMs here the GC authentication method
requires an instance presented identity
metadata token so let's actually get
this from the metadata server
note that this request doesn't require
any further authentication metadata is
returned of the JSON web token our JA
signed by Google this is what the raw
metadata contained in the token looks
like no includes the vm's identifying
information as well as an expiration
time this jot expires within an hour so
we don't have to worry that'll be stolen
and reused great now that you have this
metadata shot you can just pass the
default and request an authentication
token under the role that we created
earlier let's do that vault will confirm
via VMs identity and we're turning off
token and lease information showing how
long this token is valid now that we
have this token we can use it to get our
payments API key from vault
and now we have our API key so with that
we have all up and running on GCP with
the gzp back-end for authentication and
our developers can keep their payments
API key safe and if other developers
have questions on setting this up where
can they get for information
so check out vault project at i/o and
look up documentation on the GCD author
Ken it's been great to work with Google
Cloud involved thank you Andy I agree
you can also check out our blog post
linked below that details all of your
authentication options and other hashey
cartman Google collaborations see the
link in the description below thanks
everyone for watching we hope you found
this series on using hash your vault
with GC be helpful check out the links
in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel